is that true that you've met craig
brothers
um i met reg i used to speak to him
every week for half an hour
and he used to send me flowers
and little gifts
and
he actually proposed to me twice
what did you tell him i said no
i didn't think it was a very good idea
for either of us
[Music]
i grew up in the east end of london
um
i had
a very happy childhood
we were not very rich as was most of the
people in the east end but then that was
the norm for where we grew up in those
days
would you say there was a lot of crime
going on there was
um obviously when i was young i didn't
really take any notice but i know my
parents used to say about or they're
always selling knocked off stuff and it
wasn't until i met my
then to be first husband that i actually
ever got involved in crime can you tell
me how did you meet her first husband
mickey was an armed robber
and
he i suppose like a lot of
the youngsters in the east end
they wanted better and
[Music]
him and
three of his friends did an armed
robbery on a security van
and they all got called and they all
went to prison for eight years
this was prior to me meeting him i met
him when he came home
and i
saw my cousin in the market with her
husband
and they said to me what are you doing
saturday
and i said i'm not doing anything
so they said well come to this party
we're doing a party for this guy mickey
that's just come out of prison
and
i didn't want to go
for some reason i think because of all
the old films and whatever in those days
all the crooks were the ugly ones and
all the
so-called goodies i suppose the heroes
were all the good-looking ones
and i just imagined that this guy was
going to be really ugly and do i really
want to go
and
my cousin went oh please it's only just
one night you haven't got to see him
again
but he's the only one that's on his own
where he's been in prison so long
and
when we met each other we were both
pleasantly surprised
and that was it he was very charismatic
and
when my family all met him he won them
over
and to me he was this most gorgeous
handsome person and i was just totally
besotted by him
so what kind of crimes would happen
um
him and his friends they used to rob
banks
security vans
post offices
he would sit and plot his jobs with his
friends
and he said to me i'm going to work on
friday which meant you would be doing an
armed robbery
um
and for some reason they all used to
come to my house to sit and plot and i
used to
make them sandwiches and cups of tea
while they were discussing what they
were going to do he didn't hide anything
from me
and
my parents were hoping that he was going
to
get a job
and go to work
but that wasn't on his agenda
and he said no i want the good things in
life and people like me the only way we
can get it is by being robbers
so what ended up happening to mickey it
was a saturday morning
and it was very near to christmas
and he said
i'm not going to put any bullets in my
gun
he got his cartridges he emptied
everything out
he just put wadding in
and he just sealed the cartridges
and he said if i have to find my gun all
i'm going to shoot out is a load of
fluff so i couldn't hurt anybody but the
noise there'd still be the effect to the
noise
and
he never came back that day
and i was out looking for him
and six o'clock the next morning
um terry mickey's brother phoned and he
said to me
mickey's been arrested you've got to get
here straight away
and
as we walked in terry opened the door
and as i looked my mum
and all mickey's family was standing in
the lounge
and i said oh mum what are you doing
here
and with that terry held my shoulders
and he said mick is dead
and i was handed a brandy and they said
drink this linda
and i drunk here and i said what
happened
and terry said
well you know he did a robbery yesterday
apparently he got shot dead that's all i
know
and we've got to go to the mortuary to
identify him
and they lifted the cover back
and while i was doing that this
policeman went
we're really sorry it happened i'm
afraid your husband left us no choice
he said it's me or you
so i said what do you mean they said
well you faced your husband placed him
and said it's me or you
so i said you're telling me my husband
faced a policeman with a gun and said
it's me or you
say suggested you're lying and the
second autopsy was done
i was right he was shot through the back
and the bullet came out the front
and from then on
the police and i had locked holmes
what was your life like after mick's
death um
well i think when mickey died
it it sounds strange and
i don't know i've always said that when
i was told that he was shot something
happened to my brain because i decided
i've got to revenge my husband
because they've done this to him
so
i decided i would become a bank robber
and i would take over
from what he did
and i became the boss of the gang
what kind of crimes were you involved in
armed robberies
banks post offices exactly the same as
him
and we were very successful
how did it feel like to be a female
gangster did male
gangsters treat you differently
um
i think they did they they all respected
me
and i actually gradually did become the
boss and everything was put by me should
we do this shall we do that i met loads
and loads of women that were in prison
and done lots of different crimes
um
i never ever met another girl that did
armed robberies
it used to be funny because when we used
to share everything out we'd share it
out equally whether there's three of us
four of us whatever
and they all used to go oh no linda
you're a girl we have to give you extra
and they all used to give me extra for
theirs and i just got but why are you
doing that we've all done the same thing
and i went oh no no no because
we feel you should get the extra and it
was sort of
it was weird that they all did that to
me
is that true that you've met craig
brothers
um i met reg i used to speak to him
every week for half an hour
and he used to send me flowers
and little gifts
and
he actually proposed to me twice
did you tell him i said no
i didn't think it was a very good idea
for either of us
and he said no i guess not but i think
we would have gotten well
inevitably
in the end you do get cold because the
odds go against you as time goes on
and
i was arrested
and i got seven years from robbery
which was
i had the biggest sentence in holloway
prison
so after your first sentence
what happened after that
i was home
um 18 months
i'd started a legitimate business with
my sister
and i turned my back on crime
and then
i was
with my then boyfriend
um he was out on
a day's home leave
and i picked him up
we went to my home
and as we walked in my house
the door got kicked
in and
a gunman ran in
and he was shot dead
and when they found out who i was
they then charged me with the murder
how much did you get for that
um i was charged with gangland murder
because i wouldn't say i committed the
crime
i ended up doing 18 years
what was the prison life like that
second time
some prisons were really hard
there's a lot of bullying
there's
a lot of stealing off each other there's
there's a it's like a
world in miniature
i suppose in one way i was lucky because
um
when i went to prison the first time
as were the men who went to prison
the
bank robbers were looked on as the
hierarchy that everyone in the prison
looked up to
i suppose i actually got that same from
when i went into prison the first time
and it was sort of like oh wow she's the
armed robber she's the and it
did good for me if that makes sense
that the girls all respected me
and when i went back the second time
i met a lot of the same girls that i
knew
and
i mean i was lucky i said through prison
and i never got bullied i never got
picked on i always got treated with
the utmost respect from all the girls
so i suppose in that way i was quite
lucky
you have surfed with some of the
most notorious female criminals
who did you meet in prison um i met
mayra hindley
she was
doing washing in the laundry
and i walked in with mine and
she was
singing taking washing out the machine
and i just thought how dare you sing
when you did what you did
and i just walked up and went slap
around her face
and
she stood up and went like this and when
i could get you sent back to holloway
for that
and i went holloway doesn't hold any
fears for me
and i thought just put my washing down
and walked here and i thought oh bloody
oh well i don't really want to go back
to all away but she never did report me
is that true that when you were getting
out she gave you a present
oh she gave me a a caftan and a dressing
not a dressing gown a cardigan
why do you think she gave you a present
uh because i had to do the job of
cutting her hair we're not cutting it
colouring it and
when she was in high point they said do
you know anyone in here and she looked
at the list of names and she said the
only person i know is linda
so they said well she'll have to come
and do your hair for you
and they come and saw me and said to me
um
to colour myra's hair and i said well i
don't really want to
and it was well look linda
you want to go home sausage i don't want
to go home
so they went well the governor said
he is expecting you to do her hair
would you say she was a nice person she
was horrible she was awful
really really horrible cold and hard
and nasty
she had nothing nice at all about her
towards the end of my sentence
and i started getting home leaves
i then met my third husband
and
i got engaged in the prison
and he went to my parole hearing
and said i want to marry her he was a an
honest person they checked him all out
and i think that is the main reason that
i actually got released in the end
and i've married george
a year after i came out of prison
who unfortunately died
four and a half years ago
who died of cancer
they famous quite famously call you
black widow yes
i don't take myself seriously and i
think okay
i'm the black widow you would have
called me the black widow do i care
it doesn't matter george they said oh
how do you feel about marrying the black
widow
he went
i feel honored that she's accepted me
and it was when he was dying he said to
me
you've always said you wanted to write
he said and everyone else has written
about you
do your life story and put
put the story right so i said yeah i
will
and
i started writing i wrote the black
widow my life story
i look back now
and don't recognise that person
i really don't
and it is so alien to me
that
i sort of i'm shocked at myself to think
that i actually was that person and did
do the things i did
and there is a deep regret on that
if you could
say one thing to your younger self what
would that be
don't go to that party
and then what would have been hopefully
a very different life
but then i wouldn't have had my two
children and i love them dearly
and
crime is well and truly left behind it
was a long long time ago
it doesn't pay
there's nothing good about going to
prison nothing
it wastes your life
and out of if they say does crime pay
maybe for five percent
that means 95 have wasted their lives
and their time
and it's very sad
[Music]
tomorrow
i'll sit at seven o'clock in the morning
go and get kennedy that was my sign-off
shotgun it was named after president
kennedy i said i want one chamber one
buckshot filled with rock salt and the
other one with the normal bug shot you
know right
yeah i'm not messing about with these
people they're dangerous i'm going to
shoot